Narrator:
These are the Sharks.
They have achieved
incredible success
as entrepreneurs and investors
in multiple sectors.
They all came
from humble beginnings
and are all self‐made.
The Sharks know what it takes
to build business empires
from nothing into billions.
Now they are investing
in entrepreneurs' dreams.
Who's ready to get Sili?
Now, that's a first.
Is this brilliant or what?
You remind me
of a young Kevin O'Leary.
I've proven people
in my generation can succeed.
You're not
actually profitable.
I know that my numbers
could be bigger,
and I am ready to make it
as big as it can be.
I make millionaires.
That's what I'd like
to do with you.
Narrator: This is the art
of doing business.
I want to be
in business with you.
I'm expensive.
I would have to get 51%.
This is "Shark Tank."
If you walk out of here without
a deal, you're an idiot.
‐[ Gasps ]
‐[ Sobs ]
‐Okay, guys, come on over here.
‐Good luck, guys.
Okay, remember
to smile and wave.
And do not jump around,
okay?
Man: 4... 3...
Here we go.
... 2.
Roll doors.
♪♪
Narrator:
First into the Tank
is a modern clothing line
for stylish little ones.
Oh.
[ Chuckles ]
Hey, Sharks. I'm Melissa Lay
from Portland, Oregon.
This is Scout and Penny,
my girls.
I'm asking for $100,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in my company,
SandiLake Clothing.
We are a modern
and unique clothing brand
designed by a mom,
inspired by littles,
and made for the whole family.
When I became a mom, I had
a huge shopping problem.
All I could find
for my girls to wear
were pink, princess,
sparkly‐covered items.
For boys, the options are
blue, trucks, and superheroes.
I decided if I couldn't buy
the clothes I wanted,
I would just make them.
We have created tops,
hats, and leggings
that are unisex and relevant
with today's trends.
Each item...
Mom.
...is designed and handmade
by me.
I'm a mom. That's how it is.
‐Yeah.
Melissa: Each item is designed
and handmade by me,
giving each customer a custom,
unique, made‐as‐ordered product.
But, Sharks, I need your help
to take us to the next level.
Join with me in creating
the next big name in fashion ‐‐
SandiLake Clothing.
Girls, do you want
to go give them their gifts?
‐Yeah.
‐They're right back there.
‐Yes.
‐No, other side.
Right back here.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
Go get them. You can do it.
Go get the bags.
This is like every day
at my house.
They are adorable.
Over there.
Go give it to them.
Thank you very much.
Give one to Lori.
Thank you.
That's Mr. Wonderful, Scout.
Thank you so much.
Barbara.
‐And Mark.
‐Thanks, Penny.
Give me a high five.
Ooh!
‐Yeah, girls!
Okay, come here.
‐"Be wild."
Good job, guys.
Go see Daddy, okay?
Good job.
Love you.
Go see Daddy.
That's cute.
Go ahead.
Greiner: "Yo, I'm 2."
Do you dream up these
little slogans on your own?
Yeah, so,
the matching one for that one
is "I need vacay."
Oh!
So, we kind of try to go
with whatever is, you know,
popular and trending.
That's great.
"Rad dad" is the top seller.
Absolutely.
Yeah, so...
What kind of sales do you
have over what period and how?
So, we've been open
for two years,
and we've sold $340,000,
and ‐‐
‐$340,000?
‐Yes.
How much have you sold
since January?
Since January,
we're at $67,000.
And where do you
make all of the clothing?
Previously,
when we first started,
I created my own factory
in my home,
and just recently,
we opened a Portland ‐‐
or built a relationship
with Portland Garment Factory.
What's your margin, Melissa,
on a typical shirt?
So, I sell
all kids' shirts for $22,
and it's $5.50
to make it right now.
Something really special
and unique about our company
is that, a year ago, we
actually went full‐blown viral,
and this shirt
that I'm wearing
was found in Target
by one of my friends.
So I went
to my local Portland Target,
and sure enough,
there was a whole line of them,
and it was same tank top,
white print, same design.
Someone knocked you off?
Yes.
So I took the photo, and I
posted it to all my followers.
They started re‐posting
and sharing,
and within hours, we were viral,
and our sales skyrocketed.
So, what did Target do?
I did actually
contact Target,
and it was a third party
who made it,
and they bought it from them.
And they took it out
of their stores.
‐They ‐‐
‐That's fantastic.
Good for them.
Good for Target.
It's a wonderful testimony
to the power of the little...
‐Yeah, oh, totally.
‐Wow.
‐Good for them.
‐Did you copyright your design?
I had not at the time.
We were so small,
and we still ‐‐
So they really hadn't
broken any law at the time.
No.
You know, it's
a great lesson, though...
Yeah.
...in knowing that when you have
unique designs, copyright them.
It's not a lot of money
to do so.
Yes.
O'Leary: I've learned from this
that you're a good designer,
but you don't have
the infrastructure
to play with the big guys,
because you want to pick off
one order at a time online,
which I'm not saying
is a bad business.
Yeah.
It's a cottage
hobby‐like business.
Yeah, well, I ‐‐
So, first of all,
I'm ‐‐ I'm not
a hobby anymore.
I used to be.
Melissa, your sales
are nothing!
Melissa, that's the problem.
You have $67,000 in sales.
‐Nothing.
You said in two years,
you did $340,000.
Melissa: Mm‐hmm.
But you said since January,
you've done $67,000.
Mm‐hmm.
That says
that sales are going down.
Your sales are down.
So, in 2015,
we did better
because we went viral
for that month.
But because ‐‐ because
of Target taking your design...
But ‐‐
... and making it famous,
you had a hit.
But I would love to see my shirt
go forward and be at Target.
You were a star,
and now you're fading.
I fully get...
[ Laughs ]
He's saying
you're a one‐hit wonder.
I'm still a star, Kevin!
To me, it's just SandiLake ‐‐
small everything,
including sales.
I'm out.
That's all right.
[ Laughter ]
What I want to know
is how you're marketing.
You had your viral hit,
but that's still
not enough typically.
So, what else are you doing to
drive traffic for your sales?
Yeah.
Yeah, so, we've just met with a
few people to start re‐targeting
and getting people
to follow our products
as they're roaming the Web...
Right.
...'cause, you know, moms
all look at the same thing
all the time.
But that's tough, right,
because unless you're adding
a whole lot of new followers
on social media
every day or week...
Yeah.
...you're just pitching the same
people over and over again,
and they ‐‐ they
get pitch fatigue.
Yeah.
It's going to be tough.
Okay.
Because of those challenges,
I'm out.
Okay, thank you.
There's no doubt
you're a great designer.
But here's what
the Target story tells me.
Your sales spiked,
but, you know,
once people forgot the story,
your sales actually declined.
That tells me
it's not doing it on its own.
You haven't figured out
how I'm gonna make money
from it today.
I'm out.
Okay, thank you.
Corcoran:
I have a different read
on what happened
with Target.
I say that's a lucky charm.
It's your first sign
that you're on a track
to something bigger.
Thank you.
And I really,
really believe in that.
Thank you.
I wanted to make an offer.
Oh, wow.
But I need to take
40% of the business.
And there's one contingency.
Okay.
On that 40%,
I want to sell half of that
to Grace & Lace
so you'd actually...
Oh.
Without knowing them, they
have over $8 million in sales
after three years.
Pretty remarkable.
Yeah.
But I'll tell you something ‐‐
She does it all on social media.
She's a genius at marketing.
Yeah.
It's a new world.
If you just shadow her,
you're gonna explode
your business.
But I'd like an answer
right now.
The only thing
that's hard for me is ‐‐
I know the company
that you're talking about.
Mm‐hmm.
And I know their style,
and it's a li‐‐
It's different than what I am.
Oh, no, no, no. That's ‐‐
I mean, in fact, it's something
I would never wear myself.
Let me tell you something.
They wouldn't have anything
to do with your design.
You're the designer here just
as she's the designer there.
This is to learn
the back‐end operation,
the manufacturing,
the marketing,
the online marketing, okay?
Mm‐hmm.
That's what
they're great at.
Listen, the 20% gives them
the ‐‐ the incentive to do this.
I would love ‐‐
Greiner: So, Melissa,
I'm gonna tell you something.
You know,
when I think about...
The minute ‐‐
The minute she gives ‐‐
The minute she gives
her offer, I'm out.
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Melissa has one offer
on the table from Barbara
for her kids' clothing line,
SandiLake,
but she must make a decision now
before hearing out Lori.
Greiner:
When I think about...
The minute she gives ‐‐
The minute she gives
her offer, I'm out.
‐When I think about...
‐Oh.
Wait, wait, wait.
This is really interesting.
...things that have
happened to people...
‐Oh.
‐Wait, Melissa.
‐Come on.
‐You know what she just said?
... in...
If you let her keep talking,
she's gonna go out.
No, no. I said the minute
she gives her offer,
but I also don't want
to hear the pitch.
Oh, no.
Now, that's nasty, Barbara...
It muddies the water.
...because you're trying
to lay it on me.
‐It's the Shark Tank.
‐I love it. I love it.
That's part of business,
making a decision.
She's trying to put
the blame on me.
If you walk out of here
without a deal, you're an idiot.
You know what's interesting?
Melissa, take a moment
of silence and think about it.
I ruin it for her.
You're welcome to move on
to Lori and away from me.
You get that?
But think about it
and say yes or no to me.
Barbara, I love your offer,
but I would like to hear
what Kevin and Lori have to say.
Kevin's out.
Oh. Oh, I'm sorry.
Melissa, Kevin was out
a long time ago.
You said you were happy with it,
so our relationship is over.
Oh! I would love to hear
what Lori had to say.
And I do ‐‐
‐I'm out.
‐Oh!
‐Aah!
‐Wow.
Oh!
Lori, you better
make it good.
Wow.
Now, here's what I will share,
what I was going to say...
Oh!
which, Barbara,
I like you, I respect you.
But before I even said
if I'm giving an offer
or not giving an offer,
then she went out,
so now it's all on my shoulders
how you lost a deal
or didn't lose a deal.
That's the way it goes.
This is the Shark Tank.
These kinds of situations
because...
You ‐‐ You know what?
It's your fault.
You wouldn't make a decision.
I‐I know.
Corcoran:
Lori, I wouldn't have done it
if you hadn't kept butting in
as I was talking.
I respect my fellow Sharks,
I respect Barbara,
but, Barbara ‐‐
Butting in.
...I don't think
you need an offer from me.
Wow.
What would be great
is for you
to keep growing this
slowly...
Oh.
Wow.
...building
and building it,
and I don't want to be
in this business.
I'm sorry.
I'm out.
But I think
you're going to be great.
Thank you.
And you can do it,
and you can do it
your way.
The lesson is, you should have
taken that phenomenal offer
when you had a chance.
Instead, you squandered
your opportunity.
Great offer.
Now you're paying
a horrible price.
It's terrible.
This is a classic case, which
happens in business every day,
of curiosity killed the cat.
For me, though,
it was the deal.
It was that I would be teaming
up with another company,
and I want to work with ‐‐
That's a great ‐‐ great logic.
Then ‐‐ Then that's fine.
But, Melissa, that's...
That's great logic.
And I want to work with
an investor who wants me...
But that's your confidence.
my product for me.
We ‐‐ We wish you
the best, Melissa.
Thank you.
‐Good luck.
‐Everybody's out.
‐Thank you.
And you have two beautiful
children. Congratulations.
‐Thank you.
‐Definitely.
Melissa: I came to "Shark Tank"
to get a deal with an investor
who believes in me
as an entrepreneur.
I didn't come here
to make a deal
to team up
with some other company.
I want who invests in me
to believe in me.
I thought that was jacked up,
because ‐‐
What was jacked up?
Because I ‐‐
One, I hadn't ‐‐
I had not decided yet
what I wanted to do.
You put her on the clock.
Yeah, we do that.
It's what we do.
We're Sharks.
‐Of course.
I wanted to talk to her ‐‐
That's what we do.
I thought that you were
a good partner.
Look, at the end of the day,
she didn't accept the offer,
she didn't seize opportunity.
And we can talk all we want.
She left without a deal.
You can't come in here
not knowing your numbers!
This is the Shark Tank.
We're gonna kill you.
People ask me all the time,
"Why are you so mean
on 'Shark Tank'?"
I'm not mean.
I'm just telling the truth
through the experiences
I've lived.
I was born
into a working‐class family.
I struggled
like everybody else did.
My mother was from Lebanese
descent, my father was Irish.
He was a salesman.
He sold winter clothing
for children.
I was about 7 years old
when my father died.
Those were very tough years
for me.
My dad died
when he was 37 years old,
leaving my mother alone
with two children
and a very uncertain future
ahead.
Life being what it is,
changes all the time,
my mother
met a fellow named George.
The two of them married,
and life changed dramatically.
My stepdad joined the ILO, a
division of the United Nations.
We lived everywhere.
We moved to Cambodia, Cyprus,
Tunisia, Japan,
France, Switzerland.
Every two years,
a different country.
Looking back at all the unique
cultures I've been steeped in,
you understand everybody's
challenges in the world,
not just your own.
My stepdad's
a very pragmatic individual.
He tells it like it is.
I think I learned that trait
from him.
When I got out of college,
I wanted to be a photographer
and a rock star,
and I tried being a hippie
for a few years.
My stepfather said to me,
"You're gonna starve to death.
You should go back to school
right now."
When I graduated,
I started my first company,
Special Event Television.
It made sports programming
for the networks.
Then SoftKey
started in my basement,
which eventually became
The Learning Company.
And a few years later,
I sold it for $4.2 billion.
Exactly.
If you guys
loved it so much,
how come not a dime
from any of you?
A lot of people see me as
the harsh guy on "Shark Tank."
It's so not true.
Would you rather
have me lie to you
because I'm worried
about your feelings?
I don't care
about your feelings.
I care about your money.
A Shark that is disingenuous,
that tries
to keep you feeling good
when they know
your idea has no merit
is doing you a huge disservice.
Today I'm really proud
to be an entrepreneur
and to help entrepreneurs
so they can create jobs.
There's nothing more noble
in America than doing that.
You don't start a business
out of greed
or the pursuit of money.
You do it
for the pursuit of freedom.
But I realized
in the early years
I didn't have a lot of time
for my young kids.
I was so busy with my business.
So now I try and spend
as much time as I can with them.
Everything you see
around you here, I made myself.
I worked like hell for it, and
I'm not embarrassed about it.
I'm proud to be a capitalist.
If I could go back in time
and speak to my dad, I'd say,
"Look, you taught me a lot
that's really helped me,
and just look
at our family today."
[ Breathes deeply ]
[ Sobs ]
[ Voice breaking ]
It always cracks me up.
He'd be really proud
of what I've achieved.
You know what's amazing?
Is I'm living my entire journey
all over again
through the companies
I'm funding.
The journey is so remarkable.
♪♪
My name is Joshua Parker.
I'm 18 years old,
and I'm from Canton, New York.
Dad, can you pass the syrup?
I love everything
about maple syrup ‐‐
the texture, the flavor,
the process it takes to make it,
and everything
that you can do with it.
It's just
a great natural product.
I discovered my passion
for maple syrup
when I was 11 years old.
I was captivated by the idea
that I could go to my own
backyard, tap the trees,
and make
my own delicious maple syrup.
When I was 15,
I decided I wanted
to turn it into a real business.
I knew that that meant
more equipment and more money,
and so, I was fortunate enough
that my dad was willing
to cosign a bank loan
and lend me $70,000
of his own money.
If you don't know your numbers,
you will not know your business.
I've reached a point
where I'm getting interest
from big retailers,
and I need a Shark's investment
to help me take that next step.
I've chosen to take this path.
All of my friends
have gone to college.
I've chosen to run
a maple syrup business.
Everything in my future
is dependent on this working.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Joshua Parker.
I'm from Canton, New York.
My company is Parker Maple,
and I'm seeking $200,000
for a 20% stake in my company.
When I was 11 years old,
I went on a school field trip
to learn
how maple syrup is made.
Where I expected to find
a fun afternoon,
I found something else entirely.
I found a passion
for making maple syrup.
Four years later,
I decided to turn my passion
into a real business,
and today, Parker Maple's
one of the fastest‐growing
and most innovative maple syrup
companies in the country.
Parker Maple offers an entire
line of maple products,
from maple syrup
to maple cotton candy,
and today, I'm working
to successfully bring
a unique maple product
into the national space ‐‐
maple butter...
a delicious, creamy,
and natural spread
perfect for toast,
to icing fruit,
and just about anything else.
Sharks, I've proven that
the American dream is not dead,
that people in my generation
can succeed.
We will be America's brand
for real maple.
I want to give you some
to sample.
Good job.
‐Good pitch.
‐Oh, yeah, great.
Let me give ‐‐ Lori, I'll
get ‐‐ I'll get it for you.
‐Thank you.
‐Thank you, my friend.
Maple cotton candy.
Now, that's a first.
Thank you.
And I am
a cotton candy lover.
Thank you so much, Joshua.
‐Thanks, Josh.
‐Thank you.
Tell us
what we're eating here.
This is
the, uh, maple butter here?
Yes.
So, the maple butter
is on the English muffin.
Oh, that's good.
‐Oh, wow.
‐Oh, my God.
‐I love it.
‐The spread is really good.
Thank you very much.
That is really good.
Cotton candy
is out of this world.
Joshua, how old are you?
I'm 18.
‐You're 18?
‐Okay, well, congratulations.
18.
You've come
to the right place, Joshua,
and I'm gonna tell you a little
story you're gonna appreciate.
Okay.
Before I was known
as Mr. Wonderful...
[ Laughter ]
He made maple syrup.
...I lived
and went to school
right on the border
of Vermont and Quebec.
Oh, really?
It was a military college.
I became a marksman there,
but I was also known
as Maple Man...
Really?
... because I love
maple syrup.
[ Laughter ]
No question about it.
Just when we think
he can't do one more thing.
Maple Man ‐‐
‐On Saturdays ‐‐
‐Oh, my God!
On Saturdays, I used to
get a part‐time job
making maple syrup.
I've learned
the whole process.
I know how to tap the tree,
boil the maple syrup,
all of that.
I think
this is really interesting.
Tell me more about your sales.
Maple Man wants to know.
To date, we've done
just about $360,000 in sales
since the beginning
of the company.
Well, how about this year?
By the year's end, we'll break
$1.5 million in sales.
‐Wow.
‐Yes. Yes.
‐May I interrupt you
to just ask you, what is
different about the maple syrup?
Because I taste it and
I don't see any difference.
Maple syrup in and of itself
is kind of a commodity product,
so it's really the brand
around that product.
You're just selling it
in a different format
than most people do.
Right, exactly.
So, the rollout
of the maple butter product ‐‐
We just went under
an entire re‐branding process.
I already got a $100,000 order
from Costco.
‐Wow.
‐Good for you.
You're still a long way off
from $1.5 million.
Which product? Which product?
Parker:
For the maple butter.
And what will that sell for?
For $11.99 retail.
What are your costs?
It costs me $8.46 per unit.
Wow.
Your margin's awful.
Very thin,
but that's a problem
with a high‐quality
maple product.
Right.
It's expensive to make.
Yes.
Cuban: Who's help‐‐
Who's helping you,
and ‐‐ and how much money
have you borrowed?
Because, you know, you talk
about a product re‐launch...
Yes.
... delivering
all this inventory ‐‐
That's expensive.
My dad
has helped me tremendously
through this whole process
with getting loans,
securing lines of credit.
How much loan
do you have?
The total liabilities against
the company is $300,000.
Oh.
But the assets that we have
are within $2,000 of that.
We have
the production equipment,
and then our inventory is about
$180,000 worth of inventory.
Wow.
And there's kind
of a backstory behind that.
Tell us.
I had been working on
getting a purchase order
from this one retailer.
A large substantial
$125,000 purchase order.
I thought ‐‐
I was very confident
that it was gonna come through.
I talked to them, and so I made
the decision to buy the syrup,
and the purchase order
never came through.
It never came through?
It's never over till
their check clears your bank.
Right.
It really kind of brought me
to a ‐‐ a seriously low point
in the company and for me.
But instead
of kind of falling back
and just trying
to sell the syrup,
that's when I made the decision,
"Okay, we're gonna double down.
We're gonna re‐brand.
I'm gonna pursue
this opportunity
that I have
with the big‐box stores."
Can I return
to the spectacular figure ‐‐
$1.5 million in sales
by year end?
Yes.
I wasn't quite sure
I was clear
as to how
you were gonna get there.
That's based on getting into
75 to 100 clubs with Costco.
But you don't have
those orders or commitments.
Yes?
Right.
So that's a projection
based on optimism.
Right. Yes.
I've sold product into Costco,
but I don't find
that they order the
additional stores so quickly.
Right.
They really want
to see how well it does.
I think it's gonna take you
a number of years.
I think you're optimistic
about what your sales
are going to be.
I just don't think you're
gonna make the kind of money,
and I don't think I'd get
my money back out, so I'm out.
I'm not Mr. Maple Man,
but I will give you
one piece of advice.
Yes.
This is only 114 calories.
Whenever you have
something this big
that tastes this good...
It's only 114 calories?
Wow.
‐Yeah, it's sugar.
‐... that only has 114 calories,
you should say across
the whole thing...
Wow.
Yes.
..."Only 114 calories."
‐Yeah.
‐How much does it cost?
72 cents.
And what do you sell it for?
$1.50.
No, you're selling it
for $2.99 now.
Okay.
This will be your best seller,
but in order
to be investable,
you're gonna have to scale
to enormous size,
and I just don't see you
doing that right now.
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
You're welcome.
Herjavec: Joshua, you're ‐‐
you're an amazing kid.
I got to tell you ‐‐
When I was 18 years old,
I certainly wasn't running
a business.
The work you've done
over the last three years,
it's incredible.
You remind me
of a young Kevin O'Leary.
[ Laughter ]
Maple Man!
The young Maple Man.
I think your forecast
is really optimistic.
Based on your own story,
I don't know
if it's gonna happen, but...
you've got
a long way to go.
Just not a space
that I want to be in right now.
I'm out.
Thank you.
You are a dynamo.
You are going to make things
happen no matter what happens.
I love your product,
but I don't see it
as an investment for me
because your margins
are so very low.
Right.
For that reason, I'm out,
but... I can see you making it.
Thank you.
And so, Josh, the moon slowly
set over the maple forest.
And there were ‐‐ And there were
only two people left.
There was Josh,
the handsome entrepreneur...
No way.
... and Maple Man.
Maple Man,
what are you gonna do?
Okay, so, yes, it's true ‐‐
I'm Maple Man,
and I know
this business pretty well.
The problem here, Josh,
is $200,000 for 20%
imputes
a $1 million valuation,
but you're not actually
profitable yet.
So, for any investor,
I wouldn't do this for 20%.
It would be
a huge amount of equity,
and you're
a family business.
I don't see any way
to ‐‐ to do a deal
that's gonna make sense and be
of benefit to both of us.
Maple Man is out.
‐Josh, thank you very much.
‐Thank you.
‐Yes.
‐Congrats, Josh. Good luck.
‐Yeah, good luck.
‐Nice job.
‐We wish you all the best.
‐Good luck, Josh.
‐$2.99.
‐Thank you.
Yes, absolutely.
Thank you.
Parker:
I think that in the Tank today,
I learned more
than a semester in college.
I'm gonna go home,
I'm gonna make the changes
that I think
that are right for the company,
and really take their advice.
But was he adorable, that kid.
Right?
Adorable.
This is
better than cotton candy.
It's amazing.
Put that cotton candy
in my trailer.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is
a multiuse do‐it‐all accessory
for the kitchen.
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Cyndi.
I'm asking for $75,000
for 10% of my company.
But for today's special,
I'm willing to give 12%
just for you guys.
So, have you ever
burned your fingers
trying to get a hot dish
out of the microwave?
Well, fear no more,
because the SafeGrabs
will solve that problem
and much, much more.
Let me show you
how this simple silicone mat
will change your kitchen
forever.
You simply put it
on the turntable.
Grab the bowl of soup.
Microwave as usual,
and when it's done ‐‐
beep, beep, beep ‐‐
you basically grab it
from the bottom
without burning your fingers.
And when you get
to your destination,
not only is it your trivet,
but it's also your place mat.
Is this brilliant or what?
[ Laughter ]
But wait!
We all love
a multipurpose product,
so the SafeGrabs
becomes your food cover.
Jar opener, anyone?
It's such an easy twist.
[ Laughter ]
It's a pot grabber.
You have kids?
Use it as a plate, because
it is such an easy cleanup.
For the finale, a splatter guard
to keep your microwave clean.
So, Sharks, who would like
to invest in these silicones?
[ Laughter ]
I have samples for you.
Very clever.
Any one?
It's a set.
Thank you.
There you go, Lori.
Thank you very much.
Cyndi, I'm hiring you
for every product I have
that we need to put on TV.
I'm expensive.
[ Laughter ]
Corcoran:
I have a question.
What is the retail price
of this?
For the 10‐inch,
it's $12.95,
and then for the 12‐inch,
it's $14.95.
O'Leary:
Tell me about your margins.
$10.95 for the 10‐inch ‐‐
What's it cost to make it?
About land to here, the usual
estimate is about $2.75.
How do you sell them?
Right now, Amazon and boutiques
across the nation.
What are your sales?
Okay, I'm Asian, but numbers
get me dizzy, so hold on.
Okay, so...
[ Laughter ]
For the lifetime sales up to now
is $310,000.
Over what period of time,
Cyndi?
Three years,
but the first year,
my manufacturer
basically screwed up,
so I didn't really do
a lot of sales.
What have you done
in the last three months?
The la‐‐
Year to date is $165,000.
$165,000.
Yes.
‐Wow. Good for you.
‐Cyndi, a couple questions.
Sure.
Aren't there other variations
of this product out there?
I feel like
I've seen things like this.
Yeah. I ‐‐
No, there isn't.
Nothing else out there
that would protect my hand
from heat in a microwave?
Oh, there's a plastic one,
but it's big and bulky,
and it's, like,
Neanderthal‐looking.
And it doesn't f‐‐
bend, right?
It doesn't bend...
It ‐‐ It's stiff, yeah.
...'cause it's plastic,
yes, yes.
Yeah.
O'Leary:
What's your patent on it?
It says, "Patent pending."
The way that it's shaped
and that I could grab it
in the microwave.
A couple ‐‐
Cyndi, do you
make enough money
from the business today
that you do this full time?
Well, pathetically,
I live with my parents,
and they had no choice
because I didn't want to have ‐‐
I didn't want
to incur more debt,
'cause you know how much
it costs to sustain a business.
Basically,
my first manufacturer,
they kind of screwed me over,
and I was down
to $11 in my bank account.
Wow.
So I got this full‐time job
at a retail store,
and I would go into my car
during lunchtime
and do my business calls.
So, that's how
I supported myself,
and it was such a hard journey
because no one really
believed me in the beginning,
and even my parents
didn't believe me.
And for that reason,
it's so amazing
just to be standing here
in front of you guys,
'cause I watched your shows
from the beginning, episode one.
They say entrepreneurs
are the only ones
willing to work 80 hours
a week to avoid working 40.
But finally,
I think if we're on track,
I'll be finally out of debt
this year.
How much debt do you have?
Well, I just bought
new inventory.
How much inventory
do you have?
$50,000.
So you're basically
just almost breaking even.
Yes.
Are you breaking even?
I'm breaking even now.
Now.
Cuban: Cyndi, let me simplify
things for everybody.
Look, you're really
a product, not a company.
It's not really a fit
for me.
I'm out.
Thank you.
I'd like to cite what I do
in my kitchen,
because we all use
the microwave.
I always fold a towel,
and it sits in the microwave,
and after I bring
something to the counter,
I put the towel back on.
I just don't see
the vision on this one.
I'm out.
Okay, I think the challenge
is gonna be retail,
and to get this thing
into the $5 million
to $10 million
to $15 million range
where an investor like me
would make a decent return,
I think that's gonna be
pretty challenging,
'cause this product doesn't jump
off the shelf and sell itself.
You have to really
understand the merits of it.
Obviously
you've been successful
because when you
demonstrate it, it sells,
and I see why,
'cause you're ‐‐
you're kind of perky
and frisky.
Probably great on TV.
I get it, but that's ‐‐
‐Frisky.
‐Perky.
‐You know, perky, frisky ‐‐ TV.
‐I'll take that as a compliment.
I mean, it's great.
And I think
this product will do well
as long
as you can demonstrate it,
'cause I think
you're good at it.
I'm out.
Cyndi, I love the product.
I think you've done
a great job with it.
Even more importantly,
you did a great job
presenting it today.
Thank you.
I love the different uses
of the product,
but I think as powerful
and good as the product is,
it's just not a business
that I see
that I understand or enjoy.
I'm out.
Lori,
what are you gonna do?
Greiner:
I really like your product.
I think
it has a lot of merit.
Great TV product, obviously.
I also think, though,
it's a great retail product.
Every season I say it ‐‐
I make millionaires.
That's what I do.
So that's what I'd like
to do with you.
But to make you
a millionaire fast,
get you out of your parents'
home if you want to be...
Yes.
[ Laughs ]
I need a life.
...I am going to need 30%.
$75,000 for 30%,
'cause I know I'll get you
into Bed Bath & Beyond.
I know
I'll get you into Target.
You're gonna need money
to be able
to fund all of that retail
happening really fast,
and I'm happy to help as needed
to fulfill purchase orders.
So, that's my offer.
You have an offer.
What are you gonna do?
Lori, can we go with 17%?
17%?
Because I'm not just starting
from the bottom.
I already know
how to do the manufacturing,
I know how to do the freight,
bringing it in, and...
You know, I'm gonna go back
to what I said to you,
because you're
a lone‐man operation, right?
Yes.
Which is very hard.
I did it myself.
But a Shark
has tremendous value.
You know, there's just so much
that I bring to the table,
but it's also going
to take me time and effort.
So the lowest that I would go
is 25%.
♪♪
O'Leary: Are you
gonna take that, Cyndi?
25% for $75,000?
Make a decision.
And become a millionaire.
[ Laughs ]
Would you consider 20%?
‐You're over‐negotiating.
‐Be careful.
Greiner: Oh, look, I know
what I'm gonna do for you.
I know it.
All right, let's make a deal.
Good.
Whoo!
[ Laughs ]
Smart.
You can get
out of the house.
Oh!
To have a great partner
like Lori, are you kidding me?
I feel like I won the lotto!
I can finally go out
of my parents' home.
Let's go, let's go.
Come on.
Man: 4... 3... 2...
There's your mark, okay?
Roll doors.
Narrator: Next into the Tank is
what the entrepreneur believes
is a better version
of a must‐have accessory.
[ Bentley barks ]
[ Bentley whines ]
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Mikey Lickstein.
And this is
my co‐founder, Bentley.
We're from Miami, Florida,
seeking $100,000
in exchange for 15% equity
in our company, SiliDog.
SiliDog has created
the new standard in pet tags.
We all love our pets,
but the sound
of the pet tags jingling...
[ Bell jingling ]
... is so annoying.
I've created a brilliant
yet simple solution.
I started SiliDog
while getting my master's degree
and fostering Bentley.
He was thrown from a car
on the highway.
A friend saved him,
and I took him in.
Aww.
His constant scratching
throughout the night
made his pet tags jingle,
and the color and engraving
on his tags kept fading.
After going through four tags
in one month,
I set out to create
the world's best pet tags.
Made out of 100% silicone,
SiliDog tags are silent, never
fade, and even glow in the dark.
We're seeking an investment
to help grow our company
and spread our message
that every dog is a SiliDog.
Now, who's ready to get Sili?
‐Can we see it?
‐Can we see samples?
Absolutely.
We have some sample for you.
So, we've labeled them each
for you.
We ‐‐ We label it for the dog,
so as you can see...
Oh, thank you.
... made it out to your pet.
And Lori.
‐Thank you.
Mr. Wonderful.
O'Leary: Thank you.
‐Cute packaging.
‐Thank you, sir.
And if you flip it over,
you'll see it's not for you.
It's for the dog.
‐Oh.
‐I like my tag. It's cute.
So, walk me through it,
Mikey.
I go online, and I say,
"My dog's name is Lola."
You can put anything
that you would like.
You go ‐‐ go to our website,
you customize your tag,
pick it out, customize
the front, customize the back.
We make it and ship it to you
the next day.
How much do you charge me?
They sell for $19.99.
And how much is shipping?
Free shipping.
From the day I order it,
how long
does it take till I get it?
‐Three to five days.
‐Oh, that's not bad.
Lickstein: We make it the next
day, if not the same day.
What does it cost
to make it?
Uh, it costs $2.99
delivered to the customer,
and we also just started
a wholesale strategy, as well,
selling in retail.
So, Mikey,
I had a dog tag,
and it had a metal tag
on a metal clasp,
and you're right ‐‐
It drove me nuts.
So I went to the store
and bought a plastic dog tag.
What's the difference
between that and what you do?
The plastics are still noisy,
and at the same time,
they can still fade over time.
That's something
that drives me crazy,
'cause in the event
that you do have a lost dog,
you wouldn't be able
to read the information.
Where are your customers
coming from?
We attended one of the largest
pet‐product trade shows
back in March,
and we got into over 90 stores.
We thought
we were only gonna get into 30,
and on the first day,
we got into over 60.
O'Leary: Michael, you have
such wide distribution.
You must have
fantastic sales.
What are they?
‐[ Laughs ]
In ‐‐ In 14 1/2 months,
we've done $142,000 in sales.
Oh, very good.
Good for you.
How do the stores
do the customization?
So, the stores
take zero inventory.
What they sell is, they have
a SiliDog display board ‐‐
it's called
the SiliDog Starter Pack ‐‐
as well as 12 SiliPasses,
and the SiliPasses work
as a ‐‐ as a gift card
where there's
ordering instructions
and a unique scratch‐off code
on the back.
O'Leary: But you're ‐‐
But how do you pay back
the retailer for their space?
Do they get margins?
So, they pay me up front.
Okay.
I ‐‐ In order to sell
with SiliDog, you get ‐‐
It's $100.
So, I get that money up front.
And we also give them
exclusive access
to sell on the store's computer
right there.
You know what you want
on the tag,
you know which tag you want,
the store can enter it
in the computer,
and we get it like that.
Really?
And does the customer pay
then at the point of order,
or do they wait until
the merchandise comes?
They pay
right there in the store.
In advance?
In advance.
Cuban: What do you sell it
to the retailers?
$8.99.
Can you tell us
about your background?
So, my background ‐‐
I'm 24 years old.
I went
to the University of Florida,
I studied accounting
and business,
and I got my master's there,
as well.
I've only been out of school
for about a year and a half.
Corcoran: I thought
you were 12 years old.
It's just the voice
and the baby face.
Don't let it fool you.
No, you have
such a youthful air.
What's your competition
out there?
How many other tags
are there that are not metal?
Every dog tag.
There are no other tags on the
market doing anything like this.
Yeah, but you can
customize the tag.
Are there any
that are not metal?
Well, hang on.
That's not true, Mikey.
No, that's ‐‐
There's plastic tags.
Lickstein: Correct. Correct.
There's all kinds
of other tags.
How much did it cost you
to start this business?
I started this
with my own money.
I only invested $5,000
into it...
Cuban: Good for you.
... and that was the only
investment I've ever made.
‐Good for you.
‐I got to tell you ‐‐
Where do you see your sales
going for the next year?
For the next year ‐‐
That's why I'm here.
The sky's the limit.
It's gonna be endless.
We project this year ‐‐
Conservatively, we're
gonna do $200,000 in sales.
He's like Peter Pan.
There's a few other
revenue streams
that we'd like to pursue.
Like what?
Uh, licensing, for one.
What would you license
and to who?
Um, did you see
your SiliDog tag?
Yeah. Okay, so,
like a Mavs logo or whatever?
Or the Florida logo?
Yeah.
Right. Got it.
So, Mikey,
you're killing it.
What do ‐‐ What do
you need the money for?
We need the money
for more inventory.
The inventory that we bought
we thought we were gonna have
for the year.
We sold it in three months.
We need to have this
going from 100 tags a day
to thousands of tags a day
and just popping them out.
How do you make it?
Where are you
manufacturing these?
We make them all
out of my garage.
In your garage?
Yes.
O'Leary: Mike, I don't see how
this is really an investment.
You take on an investor,
you got to get ‐‐
get them back
their $100,000.
This year, we're gonna net
$100,000 after paying myself.
I'm just not gonna do
the dog‐tag thing.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Cuban: Mikey, I think
you've done a great job.
You've hustled.
You've made money.
A lot of these guys
are into the pet industry.
I'm not in that business,
and so I'm out.
Okay.
I think you're
a phenomenal money manager.
I don't think
I've ever seen someone young
walk in here and come up
with a really unique way
to get their money up front
before somebody even orders.
But it is
a customized business,
and whenever
anything's customized,
it's limited
for an outside investor.
I'm out.
These are the best pet tags
on the market.
Yeah, it's a dog tag,
and you've made
a real business out of it.
I don't think anybody
in the world except you
could have sold
100,000 of this.
And you've got
a great brand.
SiliDog ‐‐ It's cute.
I want to be
in business with you.
I'll take a flyer on it
with you.
I'll give you the $100,000
for 50%.
We'll go in half‐half.
I appreciate the offer.
I did not expect to come in
with 50% to give it,
but I‐I can't believe that I
even have an offer on the table,
so thank you.
But wait.
There could be more.
You remind me
of my ScreenMend girls.
Well, they were
younger than you.
They were in high school.
But they created
this great product.
They were making them
out of the garage.
And I did the deal
with them,
and they have now surpassed
$8 million in sales.
So similar.
But it took a lot of work.
I had to get them out of the
garage and into major retailers
and with
a major manufacturer.
I think that to give you
an offer of the $100,000,
I would have to get 51%.
‐Whoa.
‐Wow. It gets worse.
‐You're ‐‐
‐Do I hear 60%?
[ Laughter ]
Corcoran: It gets worse.
Greiner: Regardless
of what he's saying,
that's the deal that I did
with my ScreenMend girls,
and I got it
out of their garage.
O'Leary: Okay, we got that.
And like I said, they've done
$8 million in sales,
paid for both of their colleges,
and they're happy as can be.
51% is so that I would be able
to have control...
We got that.
...if we needed
to have major decisions.
Michael, you have two offers.
What are you gonna do?
I‐I know my in and outs
of this business.
I know numbers, I know how to
sell it, I know how to grow it.
Why would you need the 51%?
I want to work down
on the equity.
He's an MBA.
I know how smart you are.
I know you can sell.
And I know
you're driven and hardworking.
Well, if he's so smart,
trust him, Lori.
But...
... what I'm thinking about
is the experience
that I went through
with the ScreenMend.
I had to find for them
the very best manufacturing.
I redid
all of their packaging.
I got them into retailers
across the entire country ‐‐
major ones.
Mikey, I don't want you
to work for me.
And we did $8 million
in just a couple of years.
You don't need
to give up 51%.
O'Leary:
The two offers are very close.
One is a control offer.
One's a partnership offer.
You got to make a decision.
I would love, of course, to have
both of you come in together,
if that would be a possibility.
Is there any chance you would
come down to $100,000 for 25%?
I don't think that
that's the right deal for me.
So I'm out.
You're out?
Robert?
Because I don't have
that feel for it,
like I normally do
with a business,
it ‐‐ it's just pure you.
I'll give you $100,000
for 50%.
Robert, do you have
any flexibility?
I don't.
It's yes or no.
Is everybody else out?
We're very out.
I'm gonna go back in.
I'm gonna make you
a better offer.
Ah!
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out.
Mikey has one offer
left on the table...
$100,000 for 50%.
...for his silicone
pet tag company SiliDog.
But Barbara seems
to have had a change of heart.
I'm gonna go back in.
I'm gonna make you
a better offer.
O'Leary: Ah!
I'm gonna make you
a fair offer. All right?
I'm gonna give you
the $100,000 for 30%,
but I want to get $2 a tag
as you sell them.
Barbara, that doesn't sound
very fair.
Well, it's up to him.
What's happened there
is basically ‐‐
You're ‐‐ You're taking $2
a tag, and you're taking 30%.
Until the money
is paid back.
Can you afford $2 a unit?
Not with the wholesale
structure. I ‐‐
Mikey, I'm not gonna argue
with Barbara.
If you think that's a better
offer, power to you.
So you're ‐‐ you're
staying with your offer?
I'm staying with my offer.
With 50%.
Because ‐‐ It's ‐‐
I'm in pain now,
waiting for you
to make a decision,
I'll make it easy
for you.
I'll do the same thing.
I'll give you $100,000
for 30%
and only a $1 per tag
in royalty.
I'll tell you what ‐‐
I'll match his offer.
30%, $1 a tag.
Wait.
I can help you, Michael.
I'll do it for 75 cents.
Now make her match that.
You should decide.
That takes a lot less pressure.
Now decide ‐‐ Who do you want
to have as a partner?
I'm just having fun squeezing
Barbara's head for you.
Now you have a choice.
You've got three offers.
I'll give you $100,000,
30%, 50 cents.
‐Yeah.
‐Oh, my God.
‐Well, that's hard to beat.
‐I'm out.
O'Leary: Oh. Ouch.
I'll give you the $100,000
for 30% and 25 cents a tag.
Cuban: But wait!
I'm still out.
[ Laughter ]
Doing that to me?
‐Oh!
‐Bentley, get him!
Okay, I'm worried
about the dog dying,
so I want you
to make a decision.
♪♪
We'll take your deal.
Mine?
Yes.
Oh, my God.
Lori, we want you
to be our partner.
Welcome to the SiliDog family.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
Well, we're gonna get out
of the garage, right?
You owe me money
for getting you a better deal.
Herjavec: You do.
I really,
really appreciate it.
Yeah, you really do.
No, actually,
I'm the guy that helped you
by squeezing Barbara's hand
for you.
‐Ah.
‐Congratulations, Mikey.
‐Thank you so much, guys.
‐Good luck.
‐Thank you. Thank you so much.
‐Good job, Mikey.
Bentley, we got a deal!
[ Laughs ]
[ Voice breaking ]
This has been a long road,
and a lot of hard work.
And it's all coming true
right now.
[ Sobbing ]
[ Bentley whimpering ]
To have a Shark
on the SiliDog team
will open the door
to endless possibilities.
To have someone like a Shark
on my team ‐‐
I know I'm a killer salesman,
but to have that in my back
pocket ‐‐ Man, am I ready.